i drew oh good okay you've got like that
look going right now which i love
this thing
this thing
and this thing
and all of it like i'm a hair person the
more
the better not in certain areas but on
your head and face is perfect
thank you it's a little wiggy it's
wiggish at the moment
um
and this i'm not quite sure it's
laziness you know look it's uh it's it's
a bit cliche at this point in quarantine
but um you know what i am leaning into
it the heck with it
i know i i go the opposite like i dress
up hardcore at work
because i was too inside with my kids
doing homeschool
for you know six months and we had
summer break i was like oh summer break
now
thank you school i hope you have a great
summer by the way not that anyone can do
anything about any of this they're all
just trying to be safe and everybody's
trying to do their best
but um i'm so excited to be talking to
you the last time i saw you i stalked
you in central park
i gotta say it was
it was the funniest thing i
i had my headphones in
i think i had a hat on i was i just left
therapy i go to therapy on the upper
east and i was leaving and i had a snake
you know a head full of snakes and just
kind of parsing everything out and had
on some music and was finding my flow i
cannot believe i just said finding my
flow but i did
um you are changing the g
i was changing my chi and getting all
vibed out
and all of a sudden it was just like
the the happiest person in the world
just jumped out in front of me and i was
like ah what and it was like drew i was
like true oh my god and you were talking
you were saying something clearly so
nice because your face as always is just
glows and your huge smile
and but i couldn't hear what you were
saying so i was like
hold on i gotta shut my thing
and i took my airpods out and anyway you
were just like i gotta tell you
something i
love your wife
and i was like really that's what you're
gonna tell me
what about me it's true well i love both
of you
um and as a mother
i am so inspired by
your wife jenny mullen has an instagram
account called dictator lunches
it's like
game of game on game city for how to
feed your kid
and yet some people do it in a way i
must admit that almost makes me feel bad
like i just will never achieve this your
wife gives me hope it's like a bar i
want to meet
she does it
you know certainly not to make other
moms feel bad by by any means but you
know for jenny
she she works a lot she's busy and
the the she you know at the time she
gets to spend with the kids in the
afternoon after they come home from
school is wonderful but then they go to
bed and and her doing these lunches has
always been an extension of you know
getting to do something sweet for them
something that they'll see the next day
at school
and
they love and they appreciate and they
maybe laugh and you know there's little
messages and and so for her it's just an
extension of being able to do something
for the kids and
and a lot of people have written her you
know telling her that it's inspired them
which is of course wonderful and
yeah no it's been it's been a very uh
fun thing and to see the way it's grown
is uh is terrific
that's the thing it doesn't you know it
makes us all feel like
those are opportunities to show an
extension of our love and i can only
imagine how
much this is going to stick with them in
their life you're absolutely right drew
um apparently the other day
so it was my oldest son is now um
almost seven
and
uh our little guy just started so it was
just him for a few years but now our
little guy is in school as well
in preschool and so she gets to do his
lunches as well and apparently he came
home the other day he just got back to
in-person classes and the first day he
was there he apparently opened up his
lunchbox
because the teachers told us this that
he opened up his lunchbox looked at the
food looked at what was in it smiled
looked up about the teachers and said i
love my mom
and it's like okay there it is there it
is you cannot write it better than that
and then you know
you'll have the other side of it you
know
i've heard that uh tell me if this is
true if like jenny is like a little more
relaxed and you're a little bit more
strict is this true
i think in general yes in broad terms i
would say
i'm a bit more
oh gosh i don't know you know jenny
might jenny might beg to differ i feel
like it's been it's been very fluid i
think we've changed both of us in terms
of the things that we have more patience
with and the things that we're willing
to let go versus the things that we feel
we need to put our foot down certain
things i think she's a little bit more
strict about
certain you know food stuff perhaps you
know jenny is very healthy and as you
can see that's that's another part of
the dictator lunch is that she wants to
give our kids really good and healthy
food
and which is wonderful but you know i uh
i admit it i have a sweet tooth i you
know if the kids i mean if they happen
to be around when i'm you know inhaling
a uh a seven layer cake then i'm gonna
give him them some you know like what do
you want me to do my hands are tight by
the way your first date with her i heard
that you guys just totally laughed and
were like talking about like
prescriptions and just having a ball and
staying at the bar late will you tell me
about that date
yeah so we met actually on a blind date
we were set up uh by someone that we
have in common
i love you and uh i love it yeah it's
great it's a great story actually was on
friday the 13th uh of
july
good lord long time ago anyway um we
went out after dinner and yeah we were
just you know we were just chatting away
we were getting along by i you know it
wasn't long before we were compared we
were talking therapy and we were
comparing our uh antidepressant
medications and our dosages and you know
we found out that actually we were on
the same uh the same
drug which we're like i mean obviously
you and i were meant to be we're on the
same anti-depressant together hello
match made in heaven and um yeah so
that's how that was our first date we
were engaged six months later we were uh
married at not not three months after
that
and
we you know i think we probably got
another five to ten years until the kids
are in high school
i think both of you having a sense of
humor
clearly helped and you kept the date
rolling and 14 years later here you guys
are
[Music]